we're starting to think that someone
switched coffee brands over at riots
because they have gone into overdrive
their tactical FPS valor ant is
currently in closed beta and they've got
at least eight other projects on the go
including a fighting game an RPG and
even an animated series next on it's
jam-packed slate however is legends of
rune terror a collectible card game set
in the League of Legends universe call
another CCG we hear you sigh but sigh
not cynic because riot feels your pain
being punished for bad hands booster
packs huge gulfs between spendthrifts
and free to players not on their watch
here's what makes legends of ruin terror
like know of a CCG you played the most
fundamental change the CCG dynamic lies
at the heart of legends of runes harris
combat each game opens with one player
randomly assigned to the attacker role
for the other as defender attackers get
a play order token which means that they
have priority but and this is the big
difference the defender can then
immediately attempt to counter whatever
the attacker has thrown at them and
vice-versa
it's only when both players pass their
turns or run out of mana that the round
is considered complete and the attacker
and defender switch roles naturally
there are exceptions to this dynamic
evan flow for example spells come in
three speed types slow fast and burst
the latter can be deployed with
immediate effect without ending your
turn enabling you to effectively perform
two actions in one
if that sounds a little daunting
the Oracles eye is here to save you from
playing 40 chess this handy feature
effectively gives you a glimpse into the
future showing you the state of the
board after a sequence is played out and
removing any guesswork from the equation
legends of runeterra isn't altogether
passier and more aggressive CCG than you
might be used to case in point
summoning sickness that is the inability
to use a freshly summoned character to
attack or defend does not exist in this
dojo little wrinkles like this challenge
the CCG status quo without ever feeling
gratuitous another example that
illustrates this thoughtful
disruptiveness is its approach to mana
typically the classic system can feel
punitive if you're dealt a bad hand but
here you're given the opportunity to
funnel a maximum of three unspent mana
into a reserve that can then be used on
spells in the next round it's all serves
to put the emphasis on strategy
overlooked and leaves players feeling
that the balance of power could shift at
any given moment
as a league of Legends offshoot
runeterra has a deep reservoir of
characters to draw from so far
24 champions have made the cut that's
four in each of the games six regions
Andreas has cleverly adapted their
skills in the MOBA domain to operate
suitably yes authentically in the CCG
realm champions are more powerful than a
standard follower but they're certainly
not invulnerable and you can guarantee
that once they're in play your opponent
is going to focus their efforts on
taking them out as quickly as possible
however they are also able to level up
sometimes more than once if certain
conditions are met which grants them
game-changing abilities for example
looks in her standard form can summon
barriers to nullify damage against the
chosen Ally in play but once your rival
spends six or more manner on spells she
will level up and trigger her iconic
final spark which deals four damage at
zero mana cost
[Music]
it is however impossible to have
duplicates of the same champion in play
so while you can have duplicates in your
deck up to a maximum of three once one
card is in play the other two will
transform into spells again those spells
are analogues of the champions moves in
lol in Luxy standard form
it's prismatic barrier for example and
what you get depends on whether or not
that champion has leveled up of course
with nearly 150 champions to pick from
there's copious room for expansion down
the line already we've seen the
announcements of Quinn who can summon
her faithful a be an accomplice valor
into battle just as she can in lol it's
going to be fascinating to see who riot
brings in and how their abilities
translate to this new arena of combat
not to mention how they'll continue to
shift and disrupt established meta 'sm
there's a stigma attached to the phrase
free to play particularly amongst CCG
fans who paid to enter the booster pack
lottery and come away with yet another
dud hand thankfully legends of runeterra
does away with this system entirely
instead you can get this just by the
cards you actually need to build a
competitive deck I know you can buy
cards with coins which is the game's
premium currency or on them using
resources that you pick up in ranked
play by completing quests or by going on
expeditions rune terrors answer to a
draft mode you'll also earn wild cards
which come in four varieties common rare
epic and champion these can be exchanged
for any card of corresponding rarity
that's it no catch
a recent upheaval of the game's economy
saw the removal of the cap on daily
purchasable wild cards which would have
been nightmarish for free to players
save for the fact that the cap has also
been lifted on weekly vaults the vault
is an upgrade of all reward system that
gives you more the more you play and can
be leveled up to 13 at which points
you'll continue to earn rewards for
every 4,500 XP you attain before the
weekly reset in short riot is making
sure that everyone has a shot at a fair
fight and while those who spend can
build their dream deck quicker
anyone can create a hand to be reckoned
with if they invest enough time
[Music]
[Music]